patrisse Hill in the first part of your
three-part series on the new debt you
refer to this as the golden age of
financing why well we seem to have
easier financing and more plentiful
financing for just about anything you
want to buy or purchase than we've ever
had in our society low interest rates
easy - easy easy repayment terms even
getting debt once you if you have to go
bankrupt and getting debt after that is
very easy so in a sense even though it
has caused us to amass a huge amount of
debt we're living in a golden age I
guess you could say of financing itself
and what has been the result of that
well we've had a quite an explosion of
debt in our country and a lot of people
may not be aware but just in the last
five years or so we've doubled the
amount of mortgage debt that is that US
families and households have has doubled
to eight trillion dollars quite an
astounding sum and this is really
unprecedented in our history the just
the last two years each year we added
another one trillion dollars in mortgage
debt to our balance sheet which had
never been done before
eat and as twice as much as we had ever
done in a previous year so it's it's
really been quite a dramatic development
but it's been sort of under the screen
and many people have not been aware of
it in the macro sense what's the effect
on the economy
well debt in the in the short term or at
least immediately seems to help the
economy because what it's doing is
enabling people to spend more and go out
and purchase things buy houses purchase
cars go on vacations and many most of
these are rather large purchases because
what people are doing with their
refinancings is is is generally
big-ticket purchases so it has a very
beneficial effect and you could say it's
a very important reason that our economy
has had good solid growth for the last
three four years essentially since the
recession but in the long term the debt
does pose very serious issues and
problems for the economy such as well
the debt has to be repaid and much of
our debt as a society is now owned by
foreigners that is they're coming in and
they're actually purchasing the
mortgages that we're taking out through
these mortgage-backed securities they're
purchased the government's debt the
government securities of the that
Treasury issues and they expect
repayment you know not only on a regular
basis but eventually they want their
money back their principal back so it
creates these huge obligations for our
nation and we have an accumulated debt
now of eight trillion dollars to the
outside world that is you know we as a
nation oh that much to foreign countries
investors and central banks and so on in
foreign countries so that's that's a
number-one thing and it can also if it
poses dangerous because to the extent
that all of our growth has been financed
by debt if there is a pullback in the
cret in the if the foreigners decide
they just don't want to give us that
money anymore they find some better use
for it let's say in their own country or
they just don't like don't think we're
as good a risk credit risk anymore then
they can pull back and that leaves us
vulnerable to a very serious financial
crisis in this country when and why did
credit become so much easier than it
used to be there's it seems to be
something that's been evolving but what
happened in the mortgage market recently
has happened very very quickly and
that's really the reason that I decided
to write a series of stories on it
because I think most people were just
not aware of what's been going on I
think many of many people who've owned
home for years may not be aware that you
know it's no longer just that 30-year
loan that you you may have taken out ten
years
or whatever there's so many different
exotic kinds of instruments that you can
get different kinds of animals different
ways of paying and so there's been a
very rapid evolution of the kinds of
bowing that you can do in the especially
the mortgage market within the last week
Patrice Hill who is the chief economics
correspondent for The Washington Times
has written a three-part series on the
new debt here they are American Dream
putting homeowners in deep debt too good
to be true offers leave borrowers in a
bind and finally Federal directive
targets risky mortgage practices we'll
go through these throughout the next 35
minutes but we want to get our callers
involved also Seymour Indiana you are
first up thanks for holding thank you I
just wanted to say that I am concerned
about the national debt and our own
personal debt but I think the people
forget the two are intertwined that as
the government continues to go deeper in
debt it does affect our interest rates
which affects us us personally but
having said that we are still
responsible for our own personal debt
and I see so many people in my area
specially the young generation they want
to buy homes that are two hundred two
hundred fifty thousand dollar homes and
their way over expanding their means so
they get into credit card debt and it
just gets deeper and deeper so I think
our own arrogance in some way has
created our own problems here within
this country and also on the trade
deficit I'm probably as guilty as
anybody we tend to want to have higher
wages in this country yet we want to
import products from other countries so
we can buy and cheap and you know we go
to our Walmart store and what do we see
we see generally mostly stuff from
Indonesia China and so on I would have
to say that when Sam Walton was in
control you know he prided himself on in
bringing in US made goods and that's
what we purchased but we tend to be a
little bit lazy and we don't want to
expand out and find the products that
are made here within our own country we
want to buy the cheaper products that we
sent tend to have more money left over
but it's a vicious circle that seems to
be eating at our own
really Thank You caller Latrice Hill um
actually our taste for foreign goods I
think is in a sense somewhat separate
because if we were not going so deeply
into debt we really just would not be
purchasing as many we might purchase the
same you know foreign goods but in fewer
a less amount of them it's really the
fact that we're spending beyond our
incomes now in other words was actually
as a country collectively spending more
than we earn an income at this point in
time that's the reason we're buying so
much from overseas because we we are
essentially buying more than we produce
as a country so we do still buy quite a
bit in American goods but when you're
spending so much more than you earn
you're going to end up having to buy
from overseas essentially State College
Pennsylvania good morning good morning
I'm listening to these people talking
and we're hearing from people who are
business owners mortgage financers I
guess I've often thought of myself as
the average American person but I'm a
mother of two children still at home I
have four children but two or so at home
my husband is deceased and I work as an
office manager I don't have a degree
I've never had the opportunity I'm 56
years old and for me it's it's just a
matter of getting through one month
paying the regular buying food buying
you know paying the rent I don't even
know how to begin to afford to mortgage
a home with with what I make and making
ends meet and I do I pay more rent and I
would be on a mortgage but where I'm
going to find someone to mortgage it
it's a big question now I think that our
government has sold I think our our
government has sold us out we don't need
politicians we need leaders and we don't
have leaders we're all talking about
personal debt people in our country I
think a lot of people the people who
really
care about their families are struggling
to monitor their personal debt but our
government government not leaders is not
monitoring their debt and so they're
expecting us to be responsible for our
own personal but but they're not looking
out for for the rest of four on the big
picture and the patrice said made a
comment about other countries not paying
back debt when there's something in
their country that they feel is more
important that's a very good point
because we have the katrina thing in our
country where we have people who are
suffering and in the meantime we're
sending foreign aid to how many
different countries when we're not even
looking out on our own in this big
disaster and any response to that call
it well I think she makes a very
important point which is that one reason
Americans are going so deeply into debt
is because their incomes have not been
keeping up with their idea of what they
should own I guess is what you say you
know what they want to buy and so with
incomes growing rather slowly and
sometimes we're losing purchasing power
because inflation has flared up recently
what people are doing is just saying
well I'm going to go ahead and buy what
I want or what I think I need and I'll
just put it on my credit card
even if my income doesn't cover it so I
think that is definitely a one reason
that many people believe we are going to
into debt as a as a society because we
want more than we can essentially afford
and what you mentioned about the
government is true the government is
kind of symptomatic of the problem
because the government in fact Uncle Sam
has kind of led the way as far as going
out and purchasing and buying more than
it can actually afford on the income
that it has federal government is deeply
into debt and has record deficits and
just like the general population you
write that a survey by AC Nielsen last
year found that despite having some of
the highest incomes in the world
Americans are more cash
than the citizens of any other nation
partly because they are saddled with
huge debt payments nearly a third of
Americans say they have no cash left
after they have covered essential living
expenses each month that compares with
7% of consumers in the poorer nations of
India China and Mexico isn't that
shocking I mean I would never have
thought that an average person in China
would feel less strapped for cash than
an average American but it's true and
it's not just because of the debt that
is we've been mentioning that because we
have to make our debt payments every
month but also this issue that we want
what we want what we think we have to
have is more than we can afford right
now so Americans think well I've got to
buy this and this and this and this and
this and let's see my income doesn't
quite cover it so I'll just put it on
the credit card or I'll take out a
second mortgage and I'll buy it that way
so this this may be why people feel
cash-strapped because they there's no
longer this and one of the points I make
in my article is there's no longer an
the tendency to try to live within your
means to budget to see what you can't
afford and then go out and buy it the
idea is more to decide what you want and
then later determine whether in fact
your your income could cover it
bloomberg.com reports a US Consumer
Credit Rises three point three five
billion in December consumer credit
increased by three point three five
billion to two point one six trillion
last year next call is from Panama City
Florida go ahead good morning I'm I'm 26
years old I have three children and I'm
very fortunate to say that I don't have
any debt I just bought my third home and
my my concern is for my friends better
my age who they're the people that are
my age have terrible role models we are
so concerned or I should say the people
that are my age are very concerned with
image all of my friends drive
very expensive cars they dressed very
conservatively they try to emulate I'm
sorry to say Paris Hilton Britney Spears
they live very well above their means
and I have a very nice very comfortable
job I started investing when I was 17
years old I invest in real estate I have
a very nice savings account and you know
I I I don't have the bills that my
friends do they refinance their homes
and they buy jet skis you know and
they're they're filing bankruptcy and
they're 25 years old caller what kind of
work do you do um well I I'm a
photographer part time and I'm in sales
full time and did you start I mean when
you say you started investing did you
start from scratch or was there help
from mom or dad absolutely not my father
is a landscaper and my mother works in a
grocery store and you own three homes
and have three kids and 26 years old yes
I just bought a $250,000 house I live in
the panhandle of Florida I bought a
house when I was 20 years old I bought a
$90,000 house and Destin Florida and the
real estate market and this area has
just boomed
so you don't even have mortgage debt
well I have a little bit of mortgage
debt but not much all right in this area
when I bought my home in 1998 it's in my
house tripled in value so I had to sell
and I made a very very nice profit off
of it bought another home that was very
cheap sold it made a very nice profit
off of that and you know that's just the
way that it goes down here and I'm very
fortunate that that's just what happened
but you know the thing that I worry
about is the way that the way that my
friends live and the other people that
are my age and the way that they are
going to turn around and pass it along
to their children the way that the
Nationals
is at this point in the year 2006 what
is it going to be like in 2025 in 2050
if we're at a national debt at 8 billion
right now 8 trillion right now what is
it going to be like for my children what
does it mean like for their children
caller thank you for your time this
morning Patrice Hill well I think she
hit it right on the head that was
exactly the phenomenon I was talking
about just um for someone who's a good
money manager and it sounds like this
caller is you know you can take
advantage of boom times like we've had
to really you know make money and
consolidate your debts and or even
eliminate them and be in a very good
financial situation but unfortunately
many people are just using the times to
get further and further into debt and
they see the equity and their home grow
up and they want to immediately cash in
with a refinancing of their home so they
go out and spend that financial cushion
instead of saving it or you know using
that as wealth to build on in their in
their in their life and so I think she
hit it right on the head that this is a
serious issue and also it has emerged as
kind of a generational one as she's
saying it what I found in researching
the story is that it is it is something
that you see a more pronounced urge to
go into - you say among the so-called
younger generation the 20s and 30s
30-somethings
whereas their parents the baby boomers
were more cautious and of course their
grandparents the ones who were raised
during the Great Depression are the
least likely at all of all to go into
debt and are very dead averse so as each
generation has has come along there's
been more openness to get into debt to
just splurge and spend for today and
worry about it tomorrow and as she said
now people in their 20s are in a sense
we nun debt because you know they have
debt from the time that they're
teenagers they've got their credit cards
they're to go to college they get the
massive student loans that become big
obligations from the day they start
working and they just don't ever live
without debt so the concept of being
debt-free or you know saving for another
day or you know saving to buy make a
major purchase is just not there for
that generation but resale rights by mid
2005 half of new homebuyers were
financing 100% of their home purchases
and one in five were spending half their
disposable income on housing Greensburg
Pennsylvania you're on the air hi that
lady from Florida would like to adopt me
so as I or maybe the man with a
Halliburton yeah I'm calling to you I
wanted to say a couple things one was uh
you didn't mention China and how well
they're doing they have some things we
don't have if I'm not mistaken they do
have health care there and they do have
child care it's something that we don't
have I also wanted to ask a question I
am calling on the independent line I am
an independent I will be honest I have
no idea anymore who to vote for because
on the big issues some very big in our
politicians join hands and say this is
the right thing to do I just agreed with
the NAFTA agreements and believe me I
have gone from upper middle class to
being on the poverty line now I have
watched an enormous amount of jobs
leaving this country jobs in this
country that are just absolutely
decimated and as far as credit card debt
goes I am also concerned that there used
to be protection for the consumers
credit card companies themselves are out
of control I don't think it's just a
matter of people rushing to use a credit
card the only reason I ever use a credit
card is for a car repair because without
it we cannot go to work and as for young
people my daughter is $11,000 in debt
with school debt she needs another year
one year to get a degree she's unable to
a call
[ __ ] she has tried to find work she did
work in a fast-food restaurant couldn't
make it on that and I'm not supposed to
know that right now she's working as a
dancer and I'm not talking about arena
this is a mess and it hurts the American
dream we've been sold down the river and
I don't know who to turn to Democrats
Republicans I I just don't know where to
turn
Thank You Carla thank you uh you know
it's it's very definitely for many many
people the credit cards and the mortgage
refinancing and so on have been a very
badly needed you know way of being able
to finance necessities not just luxuries
or things that people want to have but
they don't really need and so I'm not in
any way seeing that credit or debt and
itself is is a bad thing it's very
necessary at times and you're absolutely
right that there for many people it has
essentially been substituting for income
you know their incomes have gone down or
their incomes have been flat but while
their needs are growing and the debt has
been the way that they've been able to
cope with that so I perfectly sympathize
with you and I understand and it's
certainly true that as far as the
political parties go they both seem to
be able to get into debt equally easily
well the third part of your article
talks about banking regulators and
credit regulators what is the federal
Rose government in in the easy credit
mm-hmm
yes and you also raise this important
issue about the consumer protections
what I found when I was researching the
article is that many of the consumer
protection laws it you you know we're
written in the 1970s which is a whole
generation ago now and they're they're
still helpful but they're not
particularly appropriate anymore they're
not really addressing the issues and
some of the abuses that have emerged
just in the last couple of years or in
the in the 2000s
so I got a sense and many analysts think
that there's a need perhaps for updating
these consumer protection laws so that
practices which could take advantage of
consumers lack of knowledge about debt
particularly in the mortgage area those
protections will be there to prevent
people from getting built because if you
get into a mortgage that puts you way
over your head and this is a very very
serious financial problem for people it
can result in bankruptcy default loss of
your home your your greatest asset it
seems to be an area where consumer
protection would be should be paramount
and it's an area that the government has
been active in the past but there hasn't
been much done to update that recently
now we did have the federal banking
agencies come out with some guidance for
the banks on these mortgage products
that I wrote about the specifically I'm
talking about the interest only loans
where you never pay any principal only
interest on your loan for a long period
also you have the option arms they call
them where you can opt not to pay
interest or you can opt to pay it at
times but some of these loans result in
not only not paying your principal down
but you can actually add to your
principal so it builds the principal and
you end up owing more than you in the
loan you originally took out so these
loans can be quite harsh on consumers
and they're all legally they're all
legal right now yeah our state's doing
anything about this state regulations
been pretty patchy and as far as I can
tell there's really not anything being
done that's doing any any money any
significant thing to curb this practice
the mortgage market is about a 2.8
trillion dollar market banks and savings
and loans are providing less than half
of that currently and in fact Patrice
Hill writes it is now routine to approve
loans that cover 100 percent or more of
a home's value and require up to sixty
percent of a borrower's income to make
debt payments recently several wholesale
lenders and
that they would offer a hundred percent
loans to people who just emerged from
bankruptcy what's the thought process
behind offering that kind of loan well
what's happened is that the lenders are
no longer banks in this case the banks
would be more cautious about offering
such loans but what you're finding is
the lenders are private investors even
hedge funds you know investors who are
quite used to risk and even seeking out
risk in the sense that they want that so
they can get a greater yield on their
investment so they're willing to
underwrite these loans so that they can
get essentially a better return on their
investment and they have those are the
ones who have been pushing the edge of
the envelope into the easier and easier
credit terms because what they believe
is they're finding that these loans are
still safe and credit worthy even when
they offer these very easy terms on them
Waverly Pennsylvania you're on with
patrice hill chief economics
correspondent washington times good
morning how are you today good morning
I've been listening to your program this
morning I'm a first-time caller
and I was listening to the woman who
said how she hoped she bought a new home
she has a daughter in college and the
debt that's costing her for her tuition
and their they haven't sold their old
home you know again living out of their
means my parents grew up in the
depression and they taught me the value
of a dollar and they told me that if you
got so much coming in you can only have
so much going out I have a mortgage
that's my debt we save as much as we can
each month and put it in our savings
when I was younger I had a paper route
and I learned so much coming in so much
going out I saved my money and I
invested it and I'm not a rich person
but with the tax credit that we can get
now on my investment
I can pocket more money than ever before
and I am very thankful to the government
for doing that for us
it seems that salt money is very easy to
borrow when you can borrow a hundred
percent of the cost of a home
people turn around and they forget that
they've got that to pay they have to pay
this back and second time bankruptcies
and 13 bankruptcies and they can go out
buy a home with no credit at all it's
ridiculous it's their own fault they
haven't been taught correctly and I
believe that this is one of the things
that these lending institutions should
be telling these people no we won't give
you the money until you can clean up
your debt Thank You caller Patrice Hill
what about the role of the lending
institutions and in counseling well that
that's kind of an old-fashioned notion
now I guess you know I'm the same way I
always kind of expected a little bit of
that that my lender would be my coach
you know as well as my lender but the
new lenders that we're talking about now
the mortgage brokers who are not
attached to banks are you know really
just agents for the investors who want
to give you a loan at any you know at
any cost basically and they're not
really counseling people on their on
their Andy you know what they're to be
realistic about their financial
wherewithal and so on
and because for some people that seems
to be almost like an addiction like you
know drinking too much or something and
I totally agree with a caller I think
this is many many of these habits are
learned at from our parents it's it's
really a cultural thing and I think it's
one reason the baby boom even though
it's a kind of loose living generation
never got quite as far out on the limb
with debt as their children are now
getting because they learn something
from their parents even if they
disregarded of it much of the time about
you know trying to live with your meet
with in your meetings or have
certain standards you know of financial
standards but if the baby boomers have
not taught their children the same thing
what they're finding is the children
have even less compunctions
about just living very large on debt
with no thought to paying it off one
thing we find is that a whole generation
of people now has no even goal of paying
off their home or paying off their debts
the idea is to just to keep up with your
monthly payment that's all and to get
your monthly payment down as far as you
can and this then just make your monthly
payment every month and that's the only
real goal the idea is not to get out of
debt or to pay off or own anything
really in an msnbc.com
article by Vanessa Richardson generation
debt is going deep into the read many
economic forecasters doubt that those
under age 35 will be the first
generation not to equal or surpass their
parents standard of living Vienna
Virginia you're on the air oh thank you
for taking my call in the first time
caller the first thing that came into my
mind is a quote by Benjamin Franklin
it's something like you know take what
you have subtract what you owe and the
remainder is what you actually own
I'm very fiscally conservative and I
live in an area where there's incredible
pressure to keep up with the Joneses if
you will and I we sort of bought into
that for a while and I was talking to
the builders or Bank getting into a new
house and they caught a mortgage broker
and I used to be in the mortgage
business internationally and she said
well you know you could do a
interest-only 10-year 30 year fixed
product and I thought you're kidding
that means that I'm gambling that the
value of my house will exceed you know
my debt if I never build up any equity
if I have to sell and it terrified me
and I kept thinking about this is how
people are getting into these houses
they can't afford it and thankfully I
can't afford it and just another little
comment when I was doing international
mortgages we were doing the newly
developing countries of Estonia Latvia
Lithuania and
every mortgage pair was trying to pay
that off before the term was up and we
had incredible payoff rates and you know
they would look at it as a loss of
income of course on the lenders
perspective because if they paid it down
there was no interest penalty or you
know penalty for that and these people I
thought were so smart and I just think
that when I look at my contemporaries
they're nuts and they have nothing to
show for anything and I mean I'm I can
stay at home I'm stay at home mom
because we have save we have a small
house I have very little debt I have a
car payment because of my husband's
business that with tax tax wise
beneficial otherwise we wouldn't and we
have a mortgage and that's it I have
never paid interest a day on a credit
card and it's so liberating but I'll
tell you it happened because I was
babysitting when I was 16 years old and
we had a neighbor they were the richest
they had the Porsche and he was in
shipping and his ship sank and he had
not improper insurance and it's and I
remember a big Northwest man pulled up
and emptied the house and I was 16 years
old and it left such an impression if
you don't own it if the credit card
company owns it it's not yours and
people have forgotten this it's really
not theirs they don't own anything Thank
You caller there's three fiscally
conservative callers in a row we'll take
the next call from New Bern North
Carolina go ahead good morning yeah I'm
not rich I'm not super successful I'm 43
years old and I've struggled most of my
life I'm not in super debt although I do
have a home I put down 25% of the actual
price of the home I was able to save
that up after Hurricane Bertha and Fran
in 96 and live in a camper for two years
to do so because I lost everything in
this world but really what I'm calling
about is Japanese cars Japanese cars are
the number one import that is destroying
American economy till you cannot go out
spend thirty thousand dollars send that
to a foreign country and think there's
gonna be jobs here sure a 99-cent bic
lighter can be imported stop importing
american cars show some patriotism in
many countries you know your car would
be vandalized if you owned an American
car in France
you better believe you can protect that
24/7 because the people there are so
nationalist it's not
hate Americans they hate anything
foreign because they believe their power
they're not food oh yeah puja and citron
czar the best cars in the world they
make the best for line and so on so on
so forth we need to get like that we
need to say you know what America become
first American jobs come first
I don't want foreign stuff I think it
stinks when people next door want to go
spend all their money on Japanese cars
and then Ana you know I'm kind of happy
when I see it repossessed because in a
way that's showing them you know that
they pretty much are the reason that
America is losing jobs Thank You caller
Latrice Hill it is interesting that
we're we've brought the fiscal
conservatives out of the woodwork and I
personally think we're the they're kind
of a silent minority in our society now
because we most people are much more
deeply into debt and I think it's
interesting that you know you can see
that there is this concern out there
among people who are trying to live
within their means and budget and save
and and you know own things instead of
just being into debt for everything that
they're worried about what's happening
around them and in you know so it's R
it's a very significant issue I'd love
to hear from from debtors or people who
believe that debt is a good way of life
a way a way of lifestyle and just just
to hear your side but I think that most
of us can agree and understand what
these past callers are saying which is
that what you're trying to do is live
with you would live within your means
and when you see your neighbors you know
are able to buy a house twice as big and
three imported fancy imported cars
because they go so much deeper into debt
you can feel kind of like a chump you
know you feel like a fool because you're
sitting there in your small house with
your little domestic efficiency car and
but of course you're able to make your
mortgage payments and you won't get
repossessed and everything but you you
almost feel like you've been taken to
the cleaners
time for two more calls with our guests
Macon Georgia you're on the air with
Patrice Elle god bless you see fans I'm
a junkie myself like I'd like to tell
you a few things my granddaddy I got
running water when he was in his middle
60s in the middle Sixers oddly enough
and I asked him one day why did you do
the same things like getting a bucket of
water instead of you he water inside and
uh what do you still use the house when
you when you have commode inside after
he slopped hogs in one day I asked him
you know you still wash it off when you
ought to be taking the bath he said
buddy time that was my name I'm saving
for a rainy day
now [ __ ] not politicians do the same now
this is absolutely the way we live now
it's absolutely ridiculous
I was watching c-span one night and they
said each family in this country
Oh Oh $27,000 they did I said no wait I
paid off all my debt put my up
understand him 65 anywhere takes up a
lot beat-up old car and now we're we
have $27,000 in there now this is the
most ridiculous thing I ever heard in my
life my I've got politicians around
running everywhere you know this kind of
money now why do you think about all
these things well I think I think that
you're feel a lot way a lot of people
feel which is if you've been managing
your money in your finances in a way to
you know be able to easily pay off all
of your debts you're astonished to see
that somehow somebody out there is so
deeply in debt that they're they've
actually created an average debt for the
American public of 27,000 per person I
mean you know what that means is if you
have no debt somebody else has got to
have fifty-four thousand in debt to to
make you have the same average as them
so it's it is it is astounding and I
think you know because it is a
collective to some extent it's an
individual issue in an individual
problem but to some extent it's all
so our collective issue a social problem
that we as society will address or have
to address at some time these cumulative
deaths that we have Patrice Hill who
studied at Oberlin College in Ohio has
been with the Washington time since 1994
she's covered the feds covered Capitol
Hill financial crises around the world
global warming California power crisis
Enron she is the chief economics
correspondent for that newspaper she had
a series in The Washington Times this
past week which is hyperlinked on the
c-span org website here it is American
dream putting homeowners in deep debt
too good to be true offer leaves
borrowers in a bind and finally federal
directive targets risky mortgage
practices if you'd like to read our
series it's what we've been talking
about this morning Patrice Hill thank
you for your time this morning thank you
for having me here it's been a delight
talking with these listeners